c'est pas le premier hiver quand on
entend parler sur nos plateaux où gilles
ils ont 13 ans 14 ans maintenant la
question est qu'est-ce que c'était soit
vous la question est ce que est ce que
15 ans est ce que simone pas trop tard
on a envie de finir mais encore une fois
je vous parlait plutôt de petite
délinquance et c'est vrai que nous on
voudrait qu'il soit sanctionné très
rapidement et qu'ils comprennent que je
peux moi je vous racontais des histoires
ou ou j'interpelle 10 12 fois le même le
même gamin et ils me disent tu es
l'hiver il me dit écoute ce le juge m'a
envoyé au ski bon bah j'espère que ce
qui va m'envoyer à la mer cet été c'est
à dire qu' il n'y a plus de sanctions et
sanctionner ça fait partie de
l'éducation et moi je voudrais juste les
sanctionner mais pour les aider c'est
pas le méchant policier il ya plus de
sanctions mais nulle part
donc voilà je pense que ce gamin après
je suis pour effectivement l'abaissement
de la majorité pénale à 15 ans alors
c'est vrai que dans ceux de cette
affaire là ça n'aurait pas changé grand
chose mais ça permet quand même de ré de
commander âge de traiter un certain
nombre d'affaires puisque
l'ensauvagement commence de plus en plus
tôt l'avocat ni la france la france
orange mécanique commence de plus en
plus tôt le même réagir c'est pas comme
dans les années dans les années soixante
dix dans les années 80 y avait un lien
de bd ya une guerre des boutons et l
rsquo est ce qu'ils avaient des bons
mots pour apaiser les chemins de penser
que vous avez les bons mots pour apaiser
oui je peux je pense pas danser la seule
la seule chose à apprendre qu en
utilisant l'ont déjà ans sauvagement
déjà d'ailleurs cette année
comment vous appelez une gamine qui se
fait poignarder un couteau jeudi le pays
dont notre pays connaît un ans
sauvagement parce que ce cas n'est pas
unique on vient d'entendre le témoignage
de monsieur au début et des affaires
comme ça il y en a régulièrement sans
parler de des flics qui toi comme des
mouches avaient changé
moi je vous dire je préfère le je
préfère ce qu'a dit adama et quand il a
dit qu'est ce qu'on fait pour ces jeunes
avant oui mais ils n'ont rien donné mais
c'est lui qui amène aussi le jeu car ils
pourront bonheur qu'on vous dit à à 15
ans pour moi 15 ans c'est presque trop
tard
ceux ci voulaient prendre avant moi
j'étais à toulouse où quartier des
izards
il ya des mamans qui se sont formés pour
faire de l'aide aux devoirs pour
sensibiliser les jeunes des huit ans
plus tard et mais là ça n'a rien à voir
la majorité pénale
non mais c'est la majorité pénale gic
mon fils et moi cgd la raison c'est déjà
trop tard
oui on a maintenant il faut quand m
quand je parle des motards il a rien ils
font défoncer pénalement à partir de 13
g honnir témoignages qui le ce soir
quand il dit qu'il regrette ce qu'il a
fait quand il dit que en vrai que les
après il se rend compte que toutes ces
conneries de bon des deux n'est pas
accompagné moi moi moi ma période c'est
peut-être j'avais parlé à marc d'un
psychologue
voilà ou peut-être une personne tierce
personne qui serait extérieure de ma
famille me reparler
peut-être que je n'aurais pas pensé ça
il faut pas confondre le préventif et le
préventif et le punitifs et qu'il y ait
effectivement une prévention très forte
avant lorsque tout ce que vous avez
rappelé là moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais il la majorité final c'est
l'agent unissions une fois d'accord à
100 on l'envoie en prison à 15 ans
confie la seule c'est un quinze ans il
connaît la brise ou plus tard sa
dissolution et là je réponds je réponds
à c est là la seule solution pour
apaiser la société dans ses fictions
utiliser une appréhension efficace
qu'est-ce qui toutes les activités qui
viennent me dire que c'est à dire
l'accompagnement scolaire que les
associés des réseaux c'est ce qui est le
meilleur qui minent l bien entendu mais
risque quoi une peine criminelle en même
temps combien de temps la peine encourue
l'intense d'antan comme ça il a 14 ans
ce qui va se passer bruno je peux pas ce
que je connais pas la fermer il va
sortir très tôt parce qu'il a 14 ans
donc il en dessous des 15 ans et surtout
c'est ce que je disais avec vous dans
les loges c'est à dire que moi ce qui
pour moi le plus violent c'est que cette
dame qu'on est là bien sûr elle va
peut-être croisé l'a65 zadora maintenant
d'en pâtir si si si si ça arrive il a
raison je suis désolé si
non si ça arrive on avait des gars ici
de gens qui nous disent à moi quand j'ai
vu le témoignage de sa de cette maman de
sept soeurs de six heures mais y met
mois mais franchement on parle c'est
vrai qu'on parle sous le coup de
l'émotion mais on aimerait ont ils à il
ya quatre ans nous on n'aimerait pas le
voir sortir et croiser les amis c'est à
perpétuité pour leur sécurité elle
voulait sauver tout le monde mais moi en
force et oumar sow en soit personne
on sauve personne mais c'est à dire que
si les tweets et pour être si on
entendait le web est en vous la sanction
n'a même si elle n'a beaucoup alors donc
s'aligner pas pris devant n'y est pas
mais et vous croyez qu'on n'a aucun
sentiment
moi je suis très admiratif par les
déclarations de madame je suis touché
par les déclarations de madame c'est
normal bon on savait que c'était elle
elle reverra plus jamais ma fille ait eu
leur soeur et c'est vrai que voilà
aujourd'hui quand on entend bruno nous
dira qu' il va il a 14 ans mais on va le
voir dehors peut-être dans pas longtemps
mais ces résultats dit c'est la peine de
mort c'est juste alors pour cet enfant 3
par an qui sortent quand il a 30 ans 40
ans 50 ans 69 mais est en tout cas il
faut se pencher les centres éducatifs
fermés je me suis intéressé aux autres
et oui mais non
on suit ces sept ans la majorité la
responsabilité pénale
dix ans en grande-bretagne et 16 en
espagne balade en course et oui à 81%
donc oui 19%
[Musique]